activist alex navalny was awarded today
the 2021 sacrifice for freedom of
thought as he's imprisoned his daughter
daria navalnya received the prize on his
behalf but here now we have leonid
volkov one of his main political
advisors who will answer some questions
to you today so welcome mr volkov thank
you
and before we get on the way with the
interview some housekeeping rules from
some
yes today we are live on facebook
youtube and linkedin so please send us
your questions from wherever you're
joining uh us from
and we'll be asking them to mr volkov
during the course of this interview
maria back to you
thank you sam so mr volkov let's get
down to business what does this award
mean to you and to mr navalny
this award means a lot because it's
recognition and it's also responsibility
of course uh what makes sahara price so
special
is that it is awarded by the decision of
a european parliament so a legislative
body
representing
and elected by
all
450 million european citizens so they
kind of like entrusted
uh their
um the members of parliament their
representatives and they
gave this award to alexandria half so
it's a lot of responsibility actually
but it's also very important because we
are the pro-european movement so our
political movement clearly says that
russia has to become
a european country not only
geographically but politically
culturally economical
what kind of contact do you have with mr
navalny right now
the only contact we have is that we are
able to communicate to him through the
lawyers lawyers are allowed to visit him
so we can relay some messages and get
some feedback from him
which allows actually him to stay
informed and even like participate in
strategic planning so he doesn't
engage into like day-to-day management
of our organization it's a rather large
organization so it has some
bureaucracies uh um our work actually
like requires some
management and organization uh but on
strategic level he discusses with us all
new projects new initiatives everything
that we are doing so he's not only like
a symbol of our movement but his remains
also very active as a leader of our
movement
you know how his mental and physical
condition is
his mental and physical conditions are
fine well his mental
very good uh he is a strong man and uh
physically he even does like work out to
recover uh there was a major crisis this
spring when he had to go to hunger
strike risking his life uh 23 days of
hunger strike just to get medical
treatment because there is no health
care there in place in russian prison
since that his health has stabilized but
as the health care is completely absent
if something will happen there will be
another crisis but so far so good and or
as we put it absence of bad news is our
good news
do you think he's safer in a russian
prison than fighting
for his ideas outside the country
he's not safe
he is in custody of that very people
that tried to kill him just slightly
over a year ago so and what
the only protections that exist for him
is international attention so wild's
world cares
while every world leader meeting
including recruiting demands for alexa's
immediate release release reminds putin
of alex's unlawful detention
he could be he could feel like
relatively protected well the world
knows
he is in putin's custody and putting
beerus full responsibility
last august they didn't shoot him in his
forehead
they tried to kill him covertly so that
actually their plan was that the plane
lands and there is a dead body and
doctors say it was a heart attack so
they
don't want
to be
caught
on the crime scene and now of course
in some in some sense it protects him
but if
god forbid he gets forgotten
if situation develops that like the
focus of international attention goes
away then his life will be endangered
but having said that
we do think
and he does say
that
what he did last january when he
returned back to russia after
rehabilitation it was the right thing it
was
his he is a man of high morale and it
was a moral driven thing he belonged
there he russian citizen russian
politician who already sacrificed a lot
who did nothing wrong why should he be
afraid to return to his home country so
we don't have to engage into victim
blaming here putin as to be blamed for
this unlawful arrest for for all these
terrible things that wouldn't it to him
receiving the prize today his daughter
daria navalnya said she was afraid that
she would become
like the one in charge of giving
speeches all around the world while his
her dad is imprisoned
is navalny still the leader of the
movement from prison is he able to be as
i already told answering your first
question he is very much so he is the
leader of the movement so there is no
competition uh and no vacant seat uh he
is very much like in charge of all of
our political projects he very much
gives us shares
ideas with us actually i mean frankly
speaking
if no one listens
this is uh
one more motivation for us
to get him out of prison as soon as
possible because while he is there and
he has some spare time
he sends us through the lures a couple
of ideas every week of new brilliant
political projects and our organization
is large but still not large enough to
accommodate all of these projects and
all of these new brilliant ideas so we
really need him to get out of there to
to do the political business to do
meetings and interviews and so on so
that he can
this is we have time to work on his
ideas and actually implement and develop
his projects
but um having said that it's indeed very
important so we are not that type of a
political organization that is
interested in doing like meetings
shaking hands uh endless interviews so
actually even what we are doing here
now is quite untypical for us we
normally don't don't do things like this
because we are very project oriented
very result-oriented so we normally
consider
projects that could yield practical
concrete results we are not much giving
interviews and so on we're using the
saharafi as a unique opportunity to
reach out in a short period of time to
all 450 million europeans i gave
43 interviews during this few days in uh
strasbourg to all 27
member countries so that was important
but after this horrific we'll get back
to normal so to working not to talking
okay
so then
you mentioned that mr navalny is giving
you some ideas from prison and but also
you you are living in lithuania is your
is your movement able to operate then
when when you are abroad as well yes of
course well flexibility has always been
a very
important thing for us a key for our
survival under this pressure and this
very toxic atmosphere of putin's russia
to survive we had to be smart and very
flexible the circumstances were always
changing and we had to adopt like i mean
in 2013 alexander was allowed to be on
zabala to run an election and we were
running an electoral campaign but then
he was barred from
being on the ballot forever from
participating in an election okay we
tried to invent something else we
launched new different projects uh
projects we invented how we could
participate in an election being not
allowed to be in zybala with our smart
voting project where we kind of
accumulated endorsement from our
supporters to independent candidates and
so on so and so this new situation is
yet another change of circumstances
which we try to overcome with yet
another flexibility
we try not to regret opportunities we
have lost but we try mostly to
concentrate on new opportunities that we
could derive from this change of
circumstances like for instance to give
you an idea
while we were operating from moscow
every second or third month
some law enforcement agents would come
to our office with a search warrant and
they would seize
all
smartphones
cameras
light equipment computers tablets
whatever
pretending this to be like a material
evidence for some other criminal case
and during the last three years they
have stolen well confiscated but
technically stolen
2 000 pieces of equipment from our
office like including flash drives and
whatever
so
just just to make it impossible for us
to operate just to cause
material damage
so we never could allow ourselves to
have a large studio in moscow we always
had to work with the
very humble
and the cheapest possible set of
equipment because we knew it will be
stolen soon so now when we work from
abroad we actually could
not fear that our equipment will be
taken away tomorrow which allows us to
scale up our video production and this
year we produced more videos more
content more hours of broadcasting more
counter propaganda videos more
investigations than in any of the
previous years and reached more audience
so of course we all love moscow but
instead of like crying of being not able
from
of operating from moscow
anymore
we try to explore uh the
we try to explore the positive sides of
our new life and there are some
so let's check what's going on in social
media
someday we have any questions or
comments from our audience uh yes so we
have uh one where someone is saying what
do you say to the critics that say is an
internal russian matter and not for the
eu to debate
it is definitely not an internal russian
matter well russia first of all russia
is a neighbor but actually every country
is now
a neighbor because of technology
the world has become very small and some
things that happens somewhere reflects
everywhere in the world like i mean
right
right now
yesterday uh european parliament
sanctioned the wagner group uh russian
uh putin-linked private military company
like they're mercenaries who engaged in
uh conflicts all over the world
wagner group is recently
started trying to start a civil war in
mali and they're very active they're
like trying to
like
to well they're participating in a civil
war in mali
who cares but apparently a civil war
mali in mali would mean a next wave of
immigration crisis in europe very
clearly
it's a small world everything is
connected and expert from corruption
from russia is also of course it
reflects very much on european affairs
and
uh current russia is well it's not a
good neighbor unfortunately putin's
russia is threatening his blackmailing
as amassing troops on the ukraine border
trying to squeeze some
concessions uh from europe and so on
it's not reliable it's not a good trade
partner
democratic russia
after putin after a peaceful transition
will be a different country the largest
country
in europe in terms of population and
area would be a very important market
and a very important trade partner
the largest market in europe
uh russia
of the future will be a partner for many
projects from climate change uh from
dealing with climate change to like
better logistics and transportation very
many things that actually russia
could offer if it would be
a good neighbor and of course we don't
have to forget about the
current effects of
uh that uh export
of corruption from russia has on
european countries and european economy
like every time russian oligarch or
russian
deputy minister putin's friends
buys themselves a
chateau in france or like hotel in
austria or like luxury act in germany
they also think immediately of
bribing
local judge municipal official police
mayor because
they used to do it they operate this way
in their home countries and also they
feel more secure they don't want
questions to be asked about sources as
funds this is dangerous this is brought
in the foundations of democracy and this
is ruining the foundations of um
european society as well any other
questions from our audience some
um
one question that we all get asked very
often is uh is there a way for european
citizens to support nevada yes of course
europe is a working democracy which
means politicians have to listen to
their
constituents unlike in russia
unfortunately in russia even large
public campaigns even large protests
yield nothing so
kremlin isolated himself from themselves
from his public opinion and they just
don't give a damn about like what people
in the street are thinking so as far as
they are in control of law enforcement
as far as they are in control of media
and as far as they control in control of
electoral systems they don't care
but in europe
all means
are available
you can like european citizens european
workers you can appeal and petition to
your politicians you can raise issues
not risking imprisonment or being
poisoned
you can put pressure on your politician
not accept dirty money from russia not
to deal with putin change their position
on putin and this will help a lot you
can do some practical things
there is a very bad phenomenon which
president thomas
hendrick elvis of estonia called
strategization named after gerhard
when putin actually employs
uh european politicians after the end of
their career to the as as board members
of uh state-owned uh companies in russia
like gerhard
the former chancellor of germany became
a board member of
uh gaspron
uh he has to do nothing
and this is worth 600
000 dollars a year
and not only schedule
former austrian foreign minister karen
knight
a former french
prime minister francoise yeon former
finnish prime minister and many others
were awarded with such sales
it it is corruption it creates enormous
influence it corrupts people it makes
every european hiring politician think
twice
i don't know what will my life after
politics be but if now
i will engage in some conflict with
putin i
destroy
a very nice retirement plan option for
myself they have to think so putting
affects their judgment
put in
wants them to think
twice before like uh taking a tougher
position
on him and it's it's very efficient it's
very efficient this could be this way of
behavior could be also influenced from
inside
petition
your
politicians your representative so that
your local parliament's passed
legislation that would make it
impossible for your high-ranked
politicians to accept such positions
where they would be effectively like
bribed for doing nothing and for serving
uh putin's uh puppets and so there are
many possibilities just be open to them
and this will be of great help to civil
society in russia
has mr navalny become a symbol of
protest in russia yes definitely some
and last year the european union imposed
on six senior russian official sanctions
for their alleged involvement in the
poisoning of mr navalny what else can
the european union do to help
well that's that was definitely too
little too late so well we welcome very
much this first step because it was the
first ever implementation of new
european magnitsky sanctions regime it
was very important this first
implementation first application of
magnitsky sanctions uh were
applied to
uh those involved in uh uh poisoning of
alexi navalny not allegedly in those who
were
who are responsible for the poisoning
it's a proven
fact proven by unreasonable doubt but uh
alexey navalny himself
uh explained in his opinion
that has been published
in by the guardian uh fatah algemayne
and le monde
uh on august 20th on the anniversary of
his
assassination
why this is not enough
those
security services guys who
executed the the the assassinations the
poisoning they don't travel abroad they
don't have schengen visas they don't
have assets in europe so they
don't care about travel bonds and uh
sanctions but they do it on behalf of
the thieves
and they do it to enable
uh saves this further opportunities to
steal more money so we have to try to
fight the reason
not the consequence and that's why we're
advocating for further application of
these magnitsky sanctions not to those
who
executed the murder the murder attempt
but against those who ordered it and
these are oligarchs of putin's inner
circle and of course vladimir putin
himself
and will the awards sour the
relationship between the european union
and russia and if that's the case how
should the european union move forward
from now on
we have not to forget all of us to
distinguish between putin and russia
relations between
european union and russia
are good and will be better russian
people want to belong to europe want to
have european communities their friends
and neighbors and trade partners putin
doesn't putin is an isolationist and he
once really like to build another iron
curtain between russia and europe which
is
a crime
against history because russia of course
belongs to europe and always belongs to
europe
[Applause]
so
the relations between european union and
putin are indeed bad and will be made
worse also by the soho award
and that's okay
putin is an international terrorist and
i don't know
why and what is the reason for european
union to maintain good relations with
him
the stakeholder of price is parliament's
prize parliament's award for human
rights what is actually needed to
improve the human rights situation in
russia once again targets the reason not
the consequences it is indeed very
important that this year the award for
human rights has been avoided to someone
who is actually like anti-corruption
fighter
and we consider it as a very important
recognition of the fact that we were
able to make our point
corruption leads to violation of human
rights
why there is no freedom of speech in
russia because kleptocracy
corrupt regime can't afford freedom of
speech because people will talk about
corruption and press will investigate
their corruption
why there is no independent adviser and
no independent courts in russia because
corrupt officials can't afford to be
challenged in courts
why there is no right for freedom of
assembly anymore in russia because
kleptocrats don't want actually people
to to to protest against
their theft so
it is
because of the corruption to make
enormous corruption possible
why putin destroyed demolished all the
basic human rights in russia one by one
in the recent 20 years
has the kremlin reacted to mr navalny's
award
yes uh president putin's spokesperson
dmitry piskov replied that they don't
care
which means they care a lot
because when you hear peskov
uh
saying something you know that to
understand his words properly you always
have to revert them by 180 degrees
mr piskov himself was a target of one of
the anti-corruption foundations
investigations he actually owner of some
luxury properties in paris and he enjoys
the mediterranean where he accepts
accepts bribes from his friends or all
girls who provide him with vacations on
their yachts
how has social media helped your
movement to campaign against the
corruption of putin's regime well
as putin's regime
is based on a totalitarian propaganda
and full control of traditional media uh
so they are not allowed to be on
television since so alex navalny for the
last time appear appeared on the state
television as himself
not
depicted as a
like enemy of the people as a national
traitor and so on maybe
in 2005 or in 2007 like 15 years ago and
since that of course
uh he was never allowed to appear them
there himself only a lot of propaganda
production was there so
we don't have access to television to
radio to newspapers and so on and so on
so it's our only tool to communicate to
our supporters and to reach out to new
people and to
enlarge uh the number of our supporters
is through social media through internet
and we did it since the very beginning
of our movement since 2011.
so speaking about social media sam can
you tell us what's going on in our
accounts uh yes actually uh speaking of
supporters on social media we have had
many people uh
saying that they support the movement
and saying that they support freedom for
political prisoners sorry katarina
mercier attila
andre
uh and me on youtube has said uh it's
not only the task of russians to put
pressure on putin's aggression it is the
task of the world to free alexi navalny
and hundreds of political prisoners
which is echoes of what you've said
already
um
and then we had an interesting question
from youtube uh which where someone has
asked uh what are the chances that
russia will join the european union uh
and uh
how much would need to change in order
in russia for that to happen
many people do not know
that when putin was running for
re-election for the first time
in 2004 after his first presidential
term
he has put
on his official presidential program
that russia has to become a member of
european union
and also that russia has to become
member of nato it has been part of
putin's presidential agenda
part of his promise in 2003. so at that
point of time it was not considered that
something's not realistic and indeed it
is not something not unrealistic the
post put in russia the russia after
democratic transition might well become
part of european family i don't see any
fundamental contradictions i don't see
many fundamental obstacles on this way
of course
now
the political culture of our countries
is so different and of course there will
be like many technicalities and this
probably will take years but it is
feasible and
let me assure you
russian people especially young russian
people of course want this to happen
um and today during uh
when miss uh naval naya accepted the
speech accepted the prize today um she
made a reference to the previous winners
of the sack of prize the bel russian
opposition leaders and we had some
comments also on our social media
channels uh highlighting uh that you
know it's important for many uh people
who are prisoners political prisoners or
freedom thinkers to be you know uh to be
you know for those cases to be become
more popular people to be aware of their
cause have you spoken to the other
people across europe who are also in a
similar situation to uh mr navalny as i
stated in the very beginning
vr and it's very important for us
uh
very concerned about doing and less
concerned about talking
there are many other countries and many
other
fighters that experienced similar
problems
similar yet different and even the
political regime in belarus which is a
country very similar to russia is
different and there are some details in
how lokashanka deals with opposition and
what is a political situation in belarus
that make it different from russia we
have made a conclusion we have talked
we can talk a lot but this would be of
no practical help for uh both us and uh
people of the belarus position we follow
their fight this is a lot of compassion
of support we consider it as very
important we hope that belarus will
become also kind of a role model for
russia when they manage finally to
defeat their bloody dictator
alexander kashanka who is of course also
a war criminal and terrorist
but
if there is an opportunity for a
particular project if we can sit and do
something together which will be helpful
for both people of pillars in russia we
will immediately engage and do something
but if we talk about like let's have a
conference and convention and exchange
pleasantries and see how we support each
other we better spend this time on our
daily work
how does the work of mr navalny's
political
network and anti-corruption foundation
work now that the moscow court has
suspended them due to alleged extremist
activities
so we have to shut down our local
offices we had a network of 40 offices
in all russia's largest city every
russian city visa population over 500
thousand people used to have a local
naval office which has been very
essential for local activism it was a
place a hub where local activists could
come with their projects with their
ideas and we would support them we would
kind of like
plant the seeds of local activists in
all major cities of our country
after our organization has been declared
an extremist organization just like
al-qaeda we had to shut these offices
down because otherwise their employees
will be very much endangered actually
otherwise every
person for just being
a member of our organization being an
employee
could face up to 10 years of
imprisonment so we had to formally
dissolve the organization immediately
just to remove the imminent danger from
our
co-workers
uh
and this assumptions that we of course
very much regret i spent personally like
four years of hard work on building this
network on
recruiting these people on launching
these offices i went to every of the
cities myself
uh
and of course it has been like a major
blow but as we already discussed we
tried to concentrate on new
opportunities uh otherwise we would just
spend too much time uh trying and
regretting what we have lost
and we have not lost everything because
those seeds that we have planted will
definitely give some crops so for four
years we teach we educated local
activists how to petition how to rally
how to engage in local politics how to
run local electoral campaign now as our
office is gone this knowledge this
knowledge and experience it remains of
course and it will yield
uh important results
members of the parliament discussed
yesterday during disciplinary the
large-scale russian military built up
along the ukrainian border what's mr
navalny's position on this and the
annexation of crimea
well first of all these are two very
different topics uh i'm not alexander on
a spokesperson so i can't tell what's
his position on the recent build up
because it's a very recent news and
there is like a delay a significant
delay actually in communication with him
so he didn't have a chance to share his
position on this i can only share mine
on crimea he condemned it many times and
we acknowledge that the annexation of
premier was was unlawful it was a crime
a crime against ukraine a crime against
international law but most importantly
for us a crime against russian citizens
because when put in the next crimea
he violated russia's international
obligations the budapest memorandum of
1994. so he made russia for many years
if not generations
not a credible partner for international
relations after russia
violated such important international
obligations who would now consider
russia as as credible partner for future
uh
agreements and negotiations that that
that that's crime and also of course
that it caused sanctions that cost a lot
that that are now like an enormous
burden russian economy
so putin swore
as a president to protect russian people
and with his move to the next crimea he
actually caused a lot of damage to
russian
people so he also violated the
obligations he swore to
with regard to the recent military
buildup i still think this is an
operation
this is a blackmail operation
uh in which putin engages like to
distract opinion from
uh public opinion both in russia and in
the west from what's going on inside the
country from from the crackdown against
the position
must torture in russian prisons extra
judicial killings and north korea causes
uh shutting down memorial and all others
terrible things that are happening
instead he wants the world
to discuss
this military buildup he wants to be
important once again regarded as an
important player in international
affairs he wants president biden to call
him and it happened already and today
white house announced president biden
will call him again so
he wants to present himself also on the
lock on domestic news as someone very
important so i'm
a major player on this international
geopolitical battlefield that what he
wants to achieve and there is one very
important thing that he already achieved
unfortunately because the headlines now
are and the narrative of european
politicians now is like if putin invades
ukraine then there will be a severe
punishment but sorry he invaded ukraine
eight years ago it already happened and
then we
uh
allow ourselves to employ this language
of that if he invades
it's major achievement for putin because
we kind of
agree to forget
[Music]
the existing aggression and the civil
war and southeast of ukraine that has
already uh cost 15 000 lives
and this is of course unacceptable mr
volkov we are about to finish our
interview but before that some many
final questions or comments from our
audience
uh yes we do have one uh very
nice comment uh from alma uh on facebook
uh who was referring to uh the speech of
miss navalnaya when uh she accepted the
sacral prize uh on behalf of her father
today where she said that she was so
bold and secure in her words uh such a a
young impressive woman so i think it's a
statement to the fact as what you were
saying mr volkov that you know young
people can have an impact and it's
really making a difference here in
europe and this is and so yeah
so mr gold volkov i thank you very much
for joining us today
yeah it was a pleasure of course thank
you some for taking the questions from
our audience and thank you everyone for
watching us happy holidays and see you
soon thank you so much and happy
holidays happy holidays
you